this race that the waffle states keep
having to make laws more restrictive
about abortion did you see what Oklahoma
did this week
the moment of fertilization that's where
moment of fertilization I mean like
before she can even say what are you
thinking yeah
a third person in that room
we're very close to getting to life
begins when you share an appetizer
really uh
foreign
but the Republicans lost one of their
big stalwarts this week you know this we
had primary elections this week to see
who's going to run in November for each
party uh Madison corthon who we've had
some fun with here on the show he
I think he was the youngest member of
Congress very hard right very hard
[Laughter]
he was caught in women's lingerie he was
caught grabbing another man's penis
having a man's head in his crotch uh his
opponent had a great slogan Google
Madison corthorne
uh
but uh and he could Madison for his
credit would conceded the election of
course against another Republican he
probably wouldn't have was a Democrat
but okay conceded the election and he
put out a statement today he said it's
it's time for the rise of the new right
it's time for dark Maga
to take command yes take command of me
dark Maga
rub my nose in it and it completely
guides me guys horsing around way not a
gay thing at all
foreign
so listen uh President Biden oh this is
not good his approval rating now is
dipped into the 30s 30s is never a good
thing for a president 39 and but Biden
he's being strong I don't think he said
the greatest thing for the Democratic
party however he said look I didn't get
into this to be popular I got into this
to eat babies and groom children dad
's in Florida
but I'm telling you
between
the monkey pox and the abortion and
democracy hanging by a thread it is
enough to drive a man to drink and that
man is Johnny Depp
because
America with all that's going on America
is so obsessed with this trial right I
mean people who a month ago were posting
the Ukrainian flag now it's the poop
emoji
and I love
[Applause]
you gotta love America Americans spent
eight hours a day
with the Johnny Depp Emperor trial it's
all you [ __ ] in the bed you hit me with
a bottle you cut off my finger you're a
cokehead you're a lying [ __ ] I want to
[ __ ] your corpse
and then they turn over to Tucker
Carlson for hooray for white people